épuisé à l'issue de leur première
journée d'audience les parents d'alexia
navale quitte le palais de justice te
faisons quelques minutes auparavant le
médecin légiste détail est à la cour le
supplice de l'eau fille alexia la
cuisine johnatan se boucher les oreilles
dans nos sociétés on divorce qu'on ne
savait pas si ça n'allait pas il avait
qu'a divorce est retournée vivre chez sa
mère avec sa mère mais c'est pas un
massacre comme ça c'est qu'il ya une
raison en dessous c'est la raison et au
fur et à mesure ils disent ils à l'item
ont disparu dans son box
on ne voyait plus les mêmes faits ses
cheveux c'est pour vous dire que même
lui n'arrive pas à faire face à
l'horreur qu'il a provoqué les avocats
de la défense s'en sont allés sans dire
un mot
la journée de ce mardi s'annonce encore
une fois très longue et éprouvante pour
les deux parties